um welcome everybody to another YouTube
hang out super excited to be with you
guys here on this Thursday afternoon
coming from mcd trial I have a special
guest with me Joshua today and thought
she was a young entrepreneur that I met
I don't know about a month ago or so and
he had some challenges with his business
he had a lot of successful who's doing
what am I advice and what to do next and
since then we've helped me with some of
the graphic design work on my side so
when you see some new team is coming you
can give him all the credit for it and I
wanted to have him on to talk about his
business too and give him some advice
and allow you guys to follow along his
journey of entrepreneurship learn about
what he's going through maybe also you
know [ __ ] some advice as well so Joshua
welcome aboard man thank you uh really
happy I can't believe that I'm actually
on your channel I've been watching I've
been Carmichael them the youtube channel
for forever and it's got me through a
whole lot and I'm so ecstatic to be a
part of this love it well for people who
may not have too much context on you
wanted to give them the quick overview
of what Josh was all about what you're
doing okay so uh at the core boy I am
right now is that as a graphic designer
I studied in a music college in Boston
that's another big part of me so music
and design essentially i'm an
entrepreneur that has created and opened
several different businesses one of the
biggest business that I hope that well
that I pursued was a company called the
number eight where we had a festival
called a fest in studios a merch and
I've also opened up several other
companies different websites and such
and if it's taking me as far as to get
contracts such as out working on a
graphic design for Tim Hortons that
Samsung's important sure to a lot of
large-scale brands so I bounced a lot of
entrepreneur work and also a lot of my
work cool so what are you going through
now that then I can help with so we can
your little one on one here and also
give
some value to the community I would say
the thing that I need the most help with
is a just guidance in entrepreneurship
to be honest I have done I have immersed
myself in entrepreneurship however it's
all been a lot of instinct and a little
bit of a lot of research of course you
know some calculated risks but never for
anyone that really come as a per gig
nada to kind of like guide me through so
I'd say the biggest thing that I kind of
need help with is just like opening my
eyes to different options that I
wouldn't know myself being an
entrepreneur in graphic are you
tailoring what you're doing for graphic
design like combining your love of
graphic design in the music together
yeah yeah my my focus find like the
business that I kind of I love the most
that I would but all my passion into is
a company called the number eight as I
mentioned so right now I'm focusing on
the music side of that and looking to
pretty much bring up a lot of
independent artists and work on their
content and what is your ideal company
look like when who are the clients who
want to work with what kind of work are
you doing what is what's the what's the
vision that you want to create for
yourself well I would say the crimes
that I'd like to work with like the
vision for me would be to kind of be
able to eventually walk into my own
office I have a team of people were
essentially we're going to be publishing
and distributing music my clients would
uh would be pretty much musicians that I
believe in that I'd like to work
alongside with and essentially utilizing
their music and spreading it with the
world and I guess other clients might
even need different music what to so how
can you start doing that in a small way
and and you know I would also be careful
the words to and thinking about like the
vision is important what you're doing is
important right like walking into an
office who cares right like the first
things we like walk into an office and
having my team it's great but like this
is what I want to go out and do right
this is the inspiring vision that's
compelling me forward if it's the work
with some select artists and help
promote their music and help them get
more exposure what's preventing you from
doing that now on a small scale like is
there an artist you can go work with and
help them out look are you doing that
now or can you start doing that now well
that's that's a good question i mean
like one thing that like I think last
time you and I have met we had bring
brought up the topic of just doing it
now previously I wanted to kind of do
little bit more preliminary things and
build myself off before I kind of
relaunch my brain because my brain has
existed for about like three years now
posted for years and so right now I took
a little bit of a break from what I was
doing because a long story short I'm a
festival that kind of went south due to
unforeseen circumstances and so if gave
me a little bit of a break to kind of to
regroup and rethink what I was going to
do but it seems like I may be planning
too much and I maybe I should just go
right ahead for it and the plan right
now is actually to just go ahead with it
and just immerse myself in when I intend
on doing which I do have many artists
that I dunno if and have work with it
and have actually used utilized their
artistry to kind of create a brand that
kind of represent the music on a large
craft one so step one is creating this
large platform and in previously else I
was taking a really complicated approach
bike been kind of waiting like yeah
essentially mobile app was which was
holding me back but I think that I
should just dive into it and just kind
of get on YouTube channel building get a
Spotify channel bling and I said to just
just starting from there and work my way
up to his inventions offense i
eventually
he will happen to the court for Nicky
Morgan so the what is your platform like
you said I want to create so people know
it when is a platform that you're trying
to create you said my first step is I
need to create a platform for people
what is the platform ok so platform is I
mean it's anyway people to music today
ok so the ideal platform would be you
might and you would be Spotify another
ideal platform would you YouTube and so
I think that without both recalled
kidding tailing I think just essentially
create my brain that launched it on
these platforms or people find and
discover music and essentially work with
the branding on that ok so if you're
going to be using existing platform to
start Spotify YouTube whatever else is
out there and then the key is signing up
artist you already know some artists
yeah you know like why not just go and
get them and start working with them yes
and actually one kind of initiative
doing a I haven't yet launched just yet
but I'm going to be essentially punching
various pop-up shops where I'm going to
be featuring artists merchandise of
various artists and also spreading the
idea we'll also pretty much putting on a
presentation of what I be like would I
be doing 48 music and pretty much
enticing musicians to use my channel to
be their platform to reach more more
audiences because I find that you have
people have more success in a
collaborative audience rather than one
audience on himself by themselves for
instance if I was myself Josh Cameron
looking to publish my music on my own
channel I'd have to you know generate a
lot of momentum on my own but if me and
somebody else have decided to work
together and build this one channel and
platform and again there will be
I'm looking to make sure that any
enemies are coming through eight music
is created at a very high level to keep
audience interested in this channel so
essentially featuring the best
independent talent and so point being
I'm looking to just entice so I'm
looking to step 1 create this pop-up
shop so this public shop that I'm going
to be launching at the end of tender
possibly beginning of October I've
already secured the venue will be
essentially a place where people get
information about eight music and will
be also being to this feature their
merchandise because merchandising has
been a very strong way to generate
momentum and income in what I'm doing
and you want people you want artists to
put their content their music on your
Spotify or on your YouTube but not on
their own but the idea what no actually
you think they're they're completely
open to publish on their own but the way
the music industry works is that I'm
looking to get their permission to
publish their music so they can publish
on their own channel but first codify
specifically they can publish on their
own channel except the publishing rights
would be through me and through getting
publishing rights I am capable of then
marketing 30 use it to my to the general
audience that I'm creating around eight
music it regard to YouTube yes that it
is actually specifically through my
channel I'm looking to pretty much
create videos through these these these
pop-up shop events have some live
performances and recordings so people
could have something to take away with
and so just so youtube that's about if I
would be the two key places where i'm
looking to get people together through
this idea okay so in thinking this
through you know musicians love making
music that's what they want to do is be
in and out and i had to deal with the
marketing
and organizing events just like let me
show up and play and let me sit in my my
house or whatever my studio and record
right there's a lot of skills that you
have that could be beneficial to
musicians musicians want to get known
you know the guys who are really want to
get more well known the guys who aren't
all known want to get you know kind of
known uh I think I think the thing the
figure out for you is what is the
busiest single point of entry add value
to musicians so is it a pop-up shop is
it helping the brand themselves is it
having you distract their music is it
facilitating collaborations between
people and maybe that's like unique
content that you have on your channel or
you do like BBC one as the like people
come in and do covers of famous songs
what they do it in their own kind of
styling way mama what is the what is a
single most effective button that you
can push to get on the radar on
musicians and focus on that to get to
the point where you can make this a
full-time thing for yourself and build a
name for yourself in the industry and
then add other services other features
it's like you're one guy trying to do
everything right so like if it's the
pop-up shops then make it the greatest
thing of pop-up shop ever and feel the
model around pop-up shops focus on and
like don't worry about Spotify and
YouTube and that stuff for now it's
still part of you have your visions
where you want to go or your app or
whatever but if the pop-up shop is the
most immediate thing then you help
artists get exposure and our money
through pop-up shops and do such a great
job with these you know maybe mid level
talent guys that they look at it men
like how do we do that again or I don't
I pay you to do that again or you get on
somebody else's raided I go he did that
I was such a no such a crazy event I
want to do that put that on who's this
Joshua guy so it's so good that your
name starts reading is that the industry
is still pretty small and people talk
when you're producing quality stuff so
what is it what's that playing
you're gonna you know if it's going to
be the Spotify channel great okay what
is so amazing about your Spotify channel
that I I need I need to get on like I'm
happy to get on my channel right likes
how you start watch other videos happen
to be like create that for other people
that what do you have to make it likely
won't just be Regis proving their stuff
but right curating it or or making new
stuff like taking this this singer and
this drummer and putting them together
from different bands like it's one off
crazy collaboration but then you have
any content but that's its own strategy
right like you can just focus in on that
same it I want to match up my sick
guitar licks with some you know rapper
something and create this new thing that
Toronto has ever seen before or you know
I know you're not just focusing on
Toronto but um like what is the thing
because you have limited time you have a
ton of energy a ton of heart had a love
for what you're doing what the button
that you can push that just go all in on
that to focus your energies so that
it'll it'll spark notice you did that
with your your events the music concerts
that you put on before ah what's the
easiest thing for you to kind of focus
your effort on now while still having
the big vision but like now I can do
this I can make this a full time income
I can build a name for myself in the
music industry and then I can branch out
to do everything else okay uh I think it
definitely is the pop-up shop and i
think that uh i think you're totally
right just focusing on one thing and
then just building upon like the entire
vision afterwards and that that's
definitely parallel to what i've done
before and why i was successful with it
because before i had eight studios it
made merch I literally just had best in
the success of that music festival and
bringing it to the Juneau incorporating
a part of the Juneau fest and bringing
it to gage Park it it pretty much open
the doors for me to eventually open my
studio and so I think that the thing to
focus on that I think
that just stands out that I think I
could definitely excel on pretty much
make an incredible experience and bring
it to Toronto bring into New York bring
to wherever would be the pop-up shops
pretty much written and it does exactly
what i want to do which is always to put
a platform on for the musicians that
aren't been that deck deserve more
exposure that I completely believe in
and so um but as an added value because
it's always good to add value to what
you're doing to entice audiences and
musicians that come to my pop up shop I
would still like to at the bigger your
vision being that I would like to at my
pop up shop have for the audiences to
know that they're walking into a place
where they're going to be we're going to
be live recording certain musicians and
they could walk away from this pop-up
shop knowing they're a part of that live
recording furthermore like for them for
me to publish these be certain this
music onto Spotify to YouTube however
without pulling coming out and just
saying like this is the field like this
is like a part of the end goal it's just
going to be a part that I'm just going
to add value to my pop up shop and so
it's sure I think that year I think if
I'm understanding this correctly I think
the focus should be the pop-up shop and
essentially everything else would be
added value and I still think that
having the value in this into this event
because I'd like to take this to
different music fingers I'd like to have
pop-up shops in music venues like for
instance um Oh which all it's a cool
venue in in Toronto why is it simply my
mind but there's something cool someone
of what I'm going to became doing is a
CBC music in Hamilton they have a CBC
space people have used rented it up many
times I could maybe create a pop-up shop
there but I think in short the pop-up
shop will be the focus like their
conduct well I mean Kanye just came to
Toronto how to pop up shop for his
clothing line so whether it's in the
music venue itself or its just a shop uh
it's just making it like how do you make
a must-attend event so whether it's live
sessions with the band whether it's
photo ops whether it's exclusive merge
or whatever yeah you you put on music
festivals before you know you haven't
had a successful pop-up shop in Toronto
so like that's the next step like okay
it's what is sep tember 15 so like
October first or whatever it is I don't
know what a reasonable timeline is for
you here's the first pop-up shop and
it's got to be sick you got to have a
lot of people coming out want to
participate and like they just get so
blown away that it's not only because of
the added value is that they want more
rights like what else you have man like
how do I when's the next one I won't be
involved right whether with you you know
recruit Baines I already have some kind
of audience and they're doing like snaps
with with their fans or sing-alongs with
their fans or whatever it is like you
know you know the music industry much
better than I do but have him having
that experience that man like that was
insane value that was sick when's the
next one coming and the musicians also
feel like they got crazy value that they
got exposure that they got you know paid
you know what what they were worth for
that and you're still going out on top
to making money you know you know put
put some money in your pocket I've
figuring out what that ideal situation
looks like on the first one and then
again and again and then you can branch
out to different cities different
countries right branch out into the era
creek you like tons of ways to expand
but before you expand you gotta have
something that works it's like
franchising people want to franchise a
restaurant business before they even
have a successful location like you kid
a french eyes your company until you
have one location that works and so just
like Facebook well yeah of course but
like a lot of people don't a lot of
people they go down the route of
franchise and when their home base
location still isn't profitable and
that's why they end up most franchises
those like new startup funds will fail
you look at facebook they just started
for the college campus market and then
it expanded to be you know one of the
biggest companies in the world so
doing your thing insanely well so that
you get noticed is important and then
that will lead to up like delete the
things you haven't even thought of yet
yeah that's right so if that's the
single point of like the single thing
that you push that button you're going
to get great results from then okay like
what's the timeline to make this first
pop-up shop epic maybe I'll show out
maybe we'll do like a live stream there
something I don't know um something to
make it you know crazy with your
musicians and just provide an amazing
experience for everybody who's showing
up so you have the confidence to do it
again and again and again is rest I
believe it's like I believe you think
you can make it happen and i love it i
love that vision now you got to go and
actually prove it and do it and give
everybody the value the customers the
musicians and yourself the value that
they want to do it again yeah definitely
I'm very excited for it like i have
already already confirmed a venue
because a lot of like my company is
roots buildin em that's been the fur NOC
view in the downtown core of hamilton i
am connected with a lot of musicians
that I've been very passionate about and
I've worked with before but definitely
it's the next pop-up shop will be in
Toronto because I think Toronto is a
city that I mean if you're going to be
if you're going to make it you need to
make an in Toronto just as you've
already before Hamilton you got to be to
Toronto so I'm looking to eventually
bring that same model and for you to
Prado next yea though the guys who don't
know Hamilton is a city outside of
Toronto how many people in Hamilton um
good question i think about half a
million is it half a million in this pic
yeah what the student population it
jumps to like probably 1.3 million wow
I'm disrespecting Hamilton I didn't know
what jump that high trials like three
and a half or something the biggest city
in Canada it's about what an hour 15
minutes away how long does it take yeah
yeah yeah I've gotten from like
the core of downtown because i work in
in toronto all the way to hamilton like
50 minutes without traffic 50 minutes is
you gotta have any foot man you got a
heavy foot there's a lot of gas josh is
all gasp no boyfriend um cool so okay so
you had the first event going but even
that can you bring those same musicians
to toronto for the next one oh yeah yeah
definitely definitely a lot of it again
a lot of these musicians aren't like you
know just little startup musicians
they're actually just their act like the
musicians i've worked with in my music
festival they actually have
international uh like a peel except for
some reason the locals don't even know
about it like a friend of mine match
stubs this guy hit but he's close to 80
million views on his latest single and
he walked down the street to hamilton
people wouldn't even know and so that's
the kind of void i'm trying to fill is
more awareness of the incredible music
that's coming out of our city i mean
just just the paint a picture as to how
great dramas becoming in the music
industry is if i were to point out like
the best musicians in any genre like
hip-hop Drake jazz Michael Buble um pop
music Justin Bieber like it just really
goes on and i think that there's an RD
the weekend like the crate like just the
list does go on in the roads of talent
that goes unnoticed until they hit the
big time so I'm excited to uh yeah
justjust able to create a great part of
that pop and work with those musicians
and bring them over to Toronto as you're
asking about like if I could racing
these Hamilton musicians to Toronto they
have a lot of m's in Toronto as well so
I can't wait to take what I'm doing in
Hamilton and bring it to Toronto because
I know that there are fans 22 I would
love to support what's going on and new
fans to come for sure cool so so
timelines when is it happening in
Hamilton and when is it going to happen
in Toronto let's go month by month i
would say october beginning of october
for our hamilton
and the beginning of november for
toronto all right looking forward to it
man cool well I'm uh I'm pumped man I
wanted to do this I want to see it take
off for people who want to follow along
your journey we're all gonna make this
into a series so well we'll get an
update next month from Josh by to see
how he's doing put his feet to the fire
a little bit if he's got some progress
going but for people who want to learn
about you kind of in the meantime where
is the best place to defined you follow
you see what you're up to sure uh by
like definitely like it if you want to
add me on Facebook the more people it's
the better so you can find me on
facebook at facebook.com/ such joshua
dot Aaron Dahmer and it's kind of like
too long but on Twitter you can also
just shoot me a tweet at Joshua Moran
underscore and if you want to just find
more information but what I've been up
to in the past kind of like it's a short
timeline my website is Josh old Moran
doc CA in so yeah I also started a small
web page to kind of also track progress
I josho Moran dot CA / one word and so
you can kind of be able to watch I have
this video already posted on that
website there and I know create a
website too I'll check it out maybe
we'll update the description too i don't
daddy I'd add a description did you tell
that this Angier I literally made it
just like in an hour just an hour ago
alright cool well let's see what Joshua
can do in an hour I want to check out
this website and see um cool well thank
you for the update man i'm excited to
join you on your journey for all the
people watching super preciate it give
Joshua some love there too and hope you
guys all have a great rest of the week
continue to believe i know that's Josh
was one or two and we'll see you soon